Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous !
1983 : la guerre froide bat son plein.
Des myriades de missiles américains
sont pointées vers l’URSS.
Des myriades de missiles soviétiques
sont pointées vers les États-Unis.
Le lieutenant-colonel de l’Armée
de l’air soviétique Stanislav Petrov
a un poste particulier.
Il est en charge de surveiller
ce qui ressort d’un système
de surveillance satellite dernier cri,
qui détecte d’éventuels
missiles américains
qui décolleraient d’une base américaine
en direction de la Russie.
Il a pour instructions
de suivre une procédure claire :
si un missile est détecté, ou plus,
il doit en faire part à sa hiérarchie,
qui va ensuite déclencher
la réponse nucléaire
et donc une guerre nucléaire totale.
Un missile apparaît sur le système,
puis quatre,
provenant de bases américaines
et en direction de la Russie.
Stanislav Petrov décide d’ignorer.
Il a comme une intuition.
Il pense que c’est une fausse alerte
pour plusieurs raisons
et décide de ne pas
en faire part à sa hiérarchie.
Il a eu raison : il s’agissait d’une
erreur du système dernier cri de détection
et il a ainsi évité
une guerre nucléaire totale.
Une question qui me paraît fondamentale
est de se demander :
est-ce qu’une IA,
aussi perfectionnée qu’elle soit,
aurait pu prendre la décision salvatrice
de Stanislav Petrov ?
On entend souvent parler
de super intelligence,
c’est-à-dire du moment où l’IA
atteindra puis dépassera
des niveaux d’intelligence humaine.
Une inquiétude qui revient régulièrement
avec cette super intelligence
porte sur la désobéissance,
comme si les programmes, en atteignant
un certain niveau d’intelligence,
voudraient désobéir à leur créateur,
aux humains, à ceux qui l’ont programmé.
Mais il me semble qu’une question plus
fondamentale et plus inquiétante encore
porte justement sur l’obéissance
de ces programmes,
l’obéissance parfaite, froide,
mécanique et bête de ces programmes
à ce pour quoi ils ont été conçus.
Joseph Weizenbaum, qui est un des pères
fondateurs de l’intelligence artificielle,
et notamment le créateur du premier
chatbot dans les années 60,
explique la chose ainsi.
Il considère que le programmeur
informatique est un créateur de mondes
dont il est le seul législateur,
et qu’aucun empereur, quelle que
soit l’autorité qu’il a pu avoir,
n’a jamais eu un tel pouvoir
sur des sujets aussi dévoués.
C’est cette question, à mon sens,
qui est probablement plus inquiétante
qu’une éventuelle désobéissance
d’un programme.
Mais l’IA, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Reprenons du début.
Une définition que j’apprécie énormément
est donnée par Russel et Norvig,
deux grands pontes du domaine.
Ils nous disent que l’IA,
c’est un système informatique
qui perçoit son environnement
et optimise ses chances de succès
par rapport à un objectif.
Quelques idées là-dedans :
une idée de perception
qu’on va un peu discuter, évidemment,
et cet objectif qui doit être défini
par le programmeur humain.
Cet objectif qui ne peut pas émerger
du programme lui-même.
Il est forcément exogène,
défini par l’humain.
Et la perception, on pourrait
la découper en deux parties :
une partie de pure
captation de l’information -
par exemple une caméra, un appareil photo
pour un algorithme d’analyse d’images -
et une partie vraiment de perception -
c’est-à-dire qu’il va faire le tri
dans la donnée brute -
dans l’image
pour continuer sur notre exemple -
entre l’information qui est utile
pour atteindre l’objectif
et celle qui ne sert à rien, qui doit
être rejetée ni même considérée.
En ce sens, c’est à cet endroit-là
que tout se passe pour l’IA.
On pourrait presque dire qu’une IA est
en réalité une perception artificielle,
c’est-à-dire la capacité de trier
dans un ensemble de données brutes
ce qui compte de ce qui ne compte pas,
faire une hiérarchie dans les informations
contenues dans la donnée
pour savoir ce qui a de l’importance
et ce qui n’en a pas,
et tout cela, évidemment,
par rapport à un objectif.
Trois exemples sur le même domaine
d’analyse d’images
pour illustrer cette dépendance
de la perception par rapport à l’objectif,
en particulier dans le domaine
de l’intelligence artificielle.
Un premier exemple, peut-être un peu bête,
d’un outil qui aurait pour objectif,
à partir de photos,
de déterminer si c’est une photo de chat
ou pas une photo de chat.
Les caractéristiques qui lui serviraient
à percevoir dans l’image
s’il y a un chat ou pas,
sont très différentes du deuxième outil,
par exemple,
qui, à partir d’une photo
d’un morceau de peau d’un patient,
aurait pour objectif de déterminer si ce
patient est atteint d’un mélanome ou pas.
Ce serait encore différent pour
un système embarqué d’analyse d’images
qui devrait permettre
à un véhicule autonome
de naviguer sans heurter un mur,
un individu ou un autre véhicule.
On voit à travers ces exemples, tous les
trois de l’ordre de l’analyse d’images,
que c’est l’objectif
qui est donné au programme
qui va déterminer ce qui compte
comme information sur l’image ou pas.
La perception de l’algorithme
qui est en fait un système
de hiérarchisation de l’information -
« Ça, ça compte par rapport
à ce que je dois faire ;
ça, ça ne compte pas et je n’ai
même pas besoin de le percevoir » -
dépend de l’objectif donné.
En cela,
l’IA ou la perception artificielle,
comme on pourrait presque l’appeler,
ressemble à la perception humaine.
C’est quelque chose qui a été assez étudié
et qui l’est encore beaucoup,
qui consiste à dire que notre perception -
ce que l’on voit,
et pas seulement
notre interprétation de cela -
dépend de ce que l’on cherche à faire.
Bergson résume magnifiquement
dans cette phrase qui dit que
« l’œil ne peut voir que
ce que l’esprit est prêt à comprendre ».
De même, Aldous Huxley, dans son livre
« Les portes de la perception »,
pour pouvoir nous décrire
son expérience hallucinatoire,
part du même principe.
Il nous explique que le système nerveux,
cette partie de notre intelligence,
a une fonction avant tout filtrante
qui consiste à rejeter,
parmi l’infinité d’informations
à laquelle on est soumis en permanence,
tout ce qui n’est pas utile par rapport
à notre objectif du moment.
On peut le ressentir assez facilement
sur des expériences en ligne, par exemple,
mais aussi au quotidien.
On sait bien qu’on ne voit pas
les mêmes choses,
si l’on conduit face à un paysage
ou si on le contemple.
L’IA moderne,
en particulier le machine learning,
va apporter quelque chose
de radicalement différent à cela.
Si on garde nos exemples en imaginant
les construire sans machine learning,
avec une approche classique,
pour déterminer si on a une photo
avec un chat ou une photo sans chat,
[il faudrait] définir l’une après l’autre
chaque caractéristique qui permettrait
de comprendre si un chat est présent,
ce qui fait qu’un chat est présent
sur la photo
ou s’il n’y en a pas :
les oreilles, les yeux, une position en
fonction de toutes les espèces de chats,
de toutes les positions
qu’il pourrait avoir.
Ce serait une tâche extrêmement complexe
et encore plus complexe pour les autres
exemples que nous avons abordés.
Le machine learning va apporter
une chose extrêmement puissante
puisqu’il va permettre de déléguer
cette perception artificielle,
cette perception optimisée,
à un programme lui-même.
Il suffit schématiquement
de donner au programme
un ensemble d’exemples de photos de chats,
un ensemble d’exemples
de photos sans chat,
et de lui donner comme objectif
de déterminer dans ces images
quelles caractéristiques
seront les plus efficaces
pour déterminer si une photo provient
du premier ou du deuxième groupe.
Cette approche,
caractéristique du machine learning,
permet aujourd’hui
et chaque jour davantage
de résoudre des problèmes complexes
dans différents secteurs,
comme dans la santé, par exemple.
Il comporte aussi des limitations
qui sont maintenant connues
et de plus en plus étudiées.
Je vais vous les illustrer intuitivement
avec deux exemples,
un exemple qui provient de la vie réelle,
un exemple vrai, réel,
et un exemple qui vient de la fiction.
Dans le premier exemple,
une équipe s’est intéressée au sujet
suivant - analyse d’images, toujours.
Leur objectif était de pouvoir
déterminer sur des photos
si la photo contient un tank, un char
d’assaut, recouvert de camouflage,
ou uniquement de la végétation ?
Ils se sont constitué une base.
Une partie de la base, comme on disait,
avec des tanks camouflés
et une partie de la base
avec de la forêt ou de la végétation.
Ils ont fait tourner l’algorithme
d’intelligence artificielle
pour lui permettre justement d’arriver
à ce degré de perception
lui permettant de façon optimale
de déterminer si la photo venait
du premier groupe ou du deuxième.
En testant l’outil, ils ont eu des
métriques de performance excellentes.
Puis ils ont décidé d’utiliser l’outil
en production dans la vie réelle
et ils se sont rendu compte
que ça ne marchait absolument pas.
Après analyse, ils ont constaté
la chose suivante :
leur base de données elle-même
avait un biais.
Toutes les photos, ou presque,
de chars d’assaut
étaient prises sous un ciel nuageux,
et toutes les photos de végétation
étaient prises sous un ciel bleu.
Rationnellement et de façon très
obéissante et bête, comme on le disait,
l’algorithme a considéré
que le meilleur moyen de savoir
si la photo venait du 1er groupe ou du 2e
était de regarder la couleur du ciel.
L’objectif qui avait été donné par
le programmeur, forcément, au programme,
ne tenait pas compte
de ce qui nous paraît évident -
ça ne l’est pas pour un programme,
puisque pour un programme,
rien n’est évident -
il fallait regarder plutôt vers la
végétation et plutôt vers les chars
pour pouvoir prendre une décision.
Ce genre d’erreur peut survenir
de façon assez naturelle et assez facile
dans beaucoup de programmes.
Une dimension éthique,
problématique supplémentaire,
arrive lorsque l’on applique des
programmes d’IA sur des sujets humains.
On a mentionné la santé,
les véhicules autonomes, par exemple,
où des erreurs auraient évidemment
des conséquences très graves.
Le deuxième exemple illustre également ça
sur un sujet qui va se rapprocher aussi
de cette idée de super intelligence,
de l’intelligence surhumaine
dont on s’attend à ce
qu’elle survienne peut-être un jour.
Je vais vous parler du film de Stanley
Kubrick « 2001, l’Odyssée de l’espace ».
Dans ce film, un vaisseau spatial est
envoyé et doit arriver sur une planète.
Le voyage doit prendre
plusieurs dizaines d’années
et donc l’équipage est endormi
dans des caissons frigorifiés.
Le vaisseau, pendant ce temps-là, est
gouverné par un ordinateur de bord
qui ressemble à une super intelligence,
une IA extrêmement développée,
qui s’appelle HAL 9000
ou HAL pour les intimes.
L’équipage se réveille peu après le
départ, alors que ce n’était pas prévu,
et on se rend compte au fur à mesure
que l’ordinateur de bord, HAL,
a décidé d'exterminer l'équipage
les uns après les autres.
Je vous propose
l’interprétation suivante :
si ce n’était pas une désobéissance,
si c’était plutôt une obéissance bête,
un objectif mal défini,
est-ce que l’objectif
de HAL, du programme,
c’était peut-être d’être certain
d’optimiser le fait que le vaisseau
parvienne sur la planète ?
Après des calculs,
il ne paraît pas irrationnel de considérer
que la présence à bord d’humains
qui sont imparfaits, imprévisibles, etc.
faisait en fait baisser
la probabilité d’y arriver,
et dans sa rationalité de programme,
HAL a décidé d’agir pour optimiser
justement son objectif
et donc de tuer l’équipage
en déployant des stratégies
et des tactiques
impressionnantes de ruse et de finesse.
On se rend compte à travers cet exemple
que même pour une intelligence
artificielle surdéveloppée,
la définition de l’objectif,
qui vient de l’humain,
est complexe, fine, beaucoup plus complexe
que ce qu’on ne le croie,
et elle a un impact direct
sur cette perception artificielle,
le cœur de l’algorithme,
qui va hiérarchiser les informations
et considérer, si on se trompe,
qu’une vie humaine n’a aucune importance
par rapport à l’objectif donné
d’atteindre la planète.
Le débat de savoir quand est-ce
que la super intelligence,
c’est-à-dire l’intelligence artificielle
plus intelligente qu’un humain,
va arriver, si et quand elle va arriver,
a divisé la communauté scientifique
depuis les premiers jours de l’IA.
Par exemple, on peut citer Marvin Minsky,
un autre père fondateur de l’IA,
un expert qui nous disait en 1970
qu’il nous faudrait
entre trois et huit ans
pour atteindre des machines
qui auraient un niveau d’intelligence
correspondant à un humain moyen.
A l’inverse, quelqu’un comme Joseph
Weizenbaum, dont on a déjà parlé,
considérait que même
si des programmes informatiques
allaient réussir à accomplir
des tâches complexes
aussi bien et encore mieux
que des humains,
on ne pourrait pas considérer
qu’il s’agit d’intelligence.
A mon sens, ce qui différencie
ces deux opinions
qui sont encore présentes aujourd’hui
et qui divisent la communauté scientifique
ne portent pas vraiment sur ce
que l’IA sera capable de faire,
mais plutôt sur ce qu’est l’intelligence,
et en particulier l’intelligence humaine.
Les premiers, il me semble,
considèrent que
l’esprit humain est de la même nature
qu’un programme informatique,
certes très perfectionné,
reposant sur une machine
de même nature qu’un ordinateur,
à savoir le cerveau, juste plus puissant,
et que c’est une question de temps
mais on devrait arriver à des programmes
qui seront plus intelligents que nous.
Le deuxième groupe, je crois,
considère plutôt qu’il n’y a plus que ça
dans l’esprit humain.
Qu’on l’appelle l’intuition,
le génie, l’instinct,
le sens moral ou l’étincelle divine,
c’est quelque chose d’une nature
différente des programmes informatiques.
Peut-être ce qui a permis, par exemple,
à Stanislav Petrov
de prendre la décision
salvatrice qu’il a prise.
La question fondamentale
de la super intelligence,
plutôt que de savoir si et quand elle
va survenir, serait plutôt la suivante.
Comme pour tout programme, il faudra
définir l’objectif, la direction.
Et si ça paraît simple,
dans le cas de l’homme augmenté,
de définir dans quelle direction
on doit aller -
plus fort, plus agile ou
pour augmenter sa longévité -
la vraie question, c’est :
« La super intelligence, c’est par où ? »
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)